welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the marvel cinematic universe
is reaching its timeline even further
into the future with its most distant
confirmed title
ant-man 3 with new reports confirming
it's set to begin production next summer
recent months have also established
rumors about the movie's plot and it's
villain and hour uncovered leftover
clues from ant-man to the wasp that have
got to be connected to something right i
mean this is a movie where michelle
pfeiffer dropped a casual mention of
time vortexes that was later the whole
basis of the most critical mission of
this infinity saga so i'm gonna explain
how this marvel storyline will connect
not only the upcoming films and disney
plus series but past overlooked threats
from previous films
an amazing frightening reveal hiding in
plain sight
and this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business
okay ant-man 3 is almost guaranteed to
explore things like cassie lange
stepping up as the young avengers
stature
as well as the unexplained elements of
janet van dyne's time in the quantum
realm
it's hidden city and its probable mayor
victor von doom but there is an even
more mysterious detail from ant-man the
wasp that i was pretty shocked that the
movie never
explained the shadowy entity funding
sunny birch and his men
in their pursuit of hank pym's tech my
buyers don't take no for an answer
and i have promised results to some
dangerous people yeah
we never got an answer on that no
deleted scenes no director interviews
nothing i have in the past speculated
that this organization could be mcu
weapons developers and conglomerates
like
hammer industries or roxon maybe even
companies like oscorp though that's
technically a sony property
more and more reports are suggesting
that this source currently known only as
the benefactor
will be the villain of the upcoming
ant-man 3 and then a few months back
rumors began to swirl that the
organization behind sunny birch
is aim advanced idea mechanics headed by
the benefactor who many believe
to be modok modok okay so modok is one
of the older marvel comics villains
dating all the way back to like 1967
his name is an acronym for mental
organism designed only for killing
originally was only for computing when
the evil aim organization shoved
unremarkable agent george tarleton into
an alteration chamber to transform him
into a
living computer with an oversized head
and a robotic exoskeleton and hover
chair
then he used his psionic powers to fry
the aim leaders
and take over aim changing that c to a k
it's more or less my origin story with
new rock stars now over the years modoc
has been an
awesome villain in the marvel comics a
foe to many marvel heroes
especially captain america and the hulk
actually in later comics modoc was
revealed to be part of the
intelligentsia instrumental to the
creation of red hulk
and you know how i feel about any theory
that involves red meat ross
it was believed that the upcoming
she-hulk series could introduce modoc
or perhaps just aim or early version of
george carlton maybe a smaller figure
that could go on to be the primary
villain for the movie ant-man 3. now all
of this would make
sense aim has been part of the mcu since
iron man 3 when it was run by aldrich
killian
and in my breakdown of march's black
widow trailer in those shots of elena
bulova's medical procedure i pointed out
how that kind of looks like the letters
of
aim on nearby medical equipment and we
know that ross will play a role in this
black widow film so you know many of us
began to speculate wildly about how
black widow could set up a long game
with aim and ross as a thunderbolts
founder who later snaps
use the name to become red hulk just in
time for she-hulk yes it's very exciting
to think about but this theory did start
to feel a little less airtight see while
those letters near elena look
like aim the space before the m also
kind of makes it look like an l
like a-l-m which is a known medical
equipment manufacturer also
hulu did announce that they're
developing an animated modok series with
patent oswalt
looks real fun produced under a
different division of marvel many
believed at the time that those modoc
rumors were actually just referring to
the non-mcu animated series but still
others maintain that modoc is coming to
the live-action mcu
they believe that ant-man 3 is the title
it'll happen i believe
that modoc is already here my friends
but thanks again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business so
are you looking for a website to sell
your fan art
i've seen your sexy venom art it is
intense
present your work using squarespace's
professional portfolio designs display
projects and customizable galleries and
add password-protected pages
to share private work with clients you
can auto post your content to twitter
facebook tumblr you can also easily
import from instagram or twitter other
platforms to give your site the personal
visual flair that you want squarespace
will even sell you a url
i'm not sure if eric vos's
newrockstarsmodoc.com is available but
if it is squarespace will sell it to you
just head to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to our custom url
in the description to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
okay
so the hesitation many have with modoc
as a live-action mcu villain
is probably that the little madman is
just extremely goofy now i would say the
guardians of the galaxy movies have
proven how comic book heroes can
actually
look really cool on screen but i get it
you know the mcu villains we've seen so
far have all more or less been human
sized or larger
now modog is so cool and i would prefer
to see the mcu introduce him formally
but the biggest screenwriters in the mcu
have already established how modoc could
be revealed and arguably
already exists in the mcu see end game
writers christopher marquez and stephen
mcfeely
eminem stated in an interview last year
that modoc
is the number one villain they want to
see on screen and they pitched modoc
as a new incarnation of arnhem zola
in a robotic body essentially they're
arguing merging modoc with the
disembodied ai zola evolved into
in captain america winter soldier and
that whole robot with the chess screen
that he was in the comics
remember there was a brief visual in the
first captain america film that showed
zola's blueprints for a future robotic
body a nod to his alternate form in the
comics and now
maybe a piece of foreshadowing for his
future form
in the films and streaming series the
writers rightly point out that zola was
not necessarily destroyed in winter
soldier and they were very specific to
snake zola in as an easter egg and end
game
both in the dialogue looking for dr zola
have you seen him yeah now dr
soul no haven't haven't seen a soul and
even though
no one would be able to see him with the
naked eye a visual easter egg hidden by
the vfx team on a screen
way in the background clearly kevin
feige doesn't want us to forget about
zola
in the studio must have plans for this
talking nazi computer in a future
project while
hulu explores a different take on modoc
maybe one a bit more comic booky with
patent oswald
zola could become the mcu's modoc rising
from the ashes of hydra to the servers
of killian's company advanced idea
mechanics
deploying operatives like sunny birch to
acquire valuable technology
like the quantum tech of hank pym the
old shield employee who slipped through
his fingers
back in the late 80s preventing hydra
from ever getting its tentacles on that
tech
so yes a living computer head with a
tiny robot body on a hover chair it's
kind of bizarre sight right but one way
to offset that absurdity would be with a
dash of familiarity
like the face and voice of toby jones
that's swiss red skull stan who hitched
a ride with operation paperclip to
covertly infiltrate the american
intelligence network for decades
arnim zola a mastermind from an old age
in a new form
now naming himself modok the dark
benefactor heading up
aim to do evil things like launching the
red hulk maybe to resurrect dr
doom from his exile in the quantum realm
city either way
applying his lessons learned from past
defeats by the old era of avengers in
order to attack the new generation
join this conversation on our official
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstar
follow me on instagram eaboss follow new
rockstars and socials and subscribe to
this channel and let's hope next time
zola pops up on the screen in mcu
whether it's an ant-man 3 or
34 marth r he hits us with the best
callbacks
are you looking for this
[Music]
you